Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans "Ces idées
qui gouvernent le monde".
La laïcité a-t-elle réponse à tout ?
La laïcité est de tous les combats
politiques, idéologiques,
socioculturels et même religieux.
C'est devenu un mot fourre-tout,
qui traduit d'abord le malaise
de la société française,
de son école,
des services publics et autres
producteurs de bien commun,
partout où s'exercent
des discriminations
et des pressions,
des comportements très singuliers
qui remettent en cause
le vivre ensemble.
Mais est-ce que le transgenrisme,
par exemple,
la lutte
contre le conspirationnisme,
etc., font cause commune
avec la laïcité ?
Si tout est laïc,
alors, qu'est-ce que la laïcité ?
Au début de la laïcité,
disons à sa source,
il y a la fameuse loi de 1905,
qui établit
une liberté de conscience
entre croyants et non-croyants,
la séparation
de l'Eglise et de l'Etat
et le libre exercice des cultes,
tout cela dans le respect
de l'ordre public.
Mais d'interprétation
en interprétation
et à l'aune d'événements
symboliques et tragiques,
on pense bien sûr à la décapitation
de l'enseignant Samuel Paty
le 16 octobre 2020
ou auparavant, l'affaire du foulard
de Creil. La laïcité est devenue
une sentinelle démocratique,
un bouclier
contre l'islamisme radical,
le respect
de la liberté d'expression,
un viatique républicain
de l'apprentissage de la liberté,
de l'égalité et de la fraternité.
Cette extension
du domaine de la laïcité
renforce-t-elle
sa prégnance socioculturelle
ou, a contrario, est-elle le constat
de l'affaissement du politique
et de la politique
au profit des communautarismes
et de la tenaille identitaire ?
C'est ce que nous allons voir
avec mes invités. Alors,
Iannis Roder,
vous êtes professeur d'histoire,
directeur de l'Observatoire
de l'Education à de la Fondation
Jean Jaurès.
Smaïn Laacher, vous êtes sociologue,
professeur des universités,
directeur
de l'Observatoire
du Fait migratoire et de l'Asile
à la Fondation Jean Jaurès. Laetitia
Strauch-Bonart,
vous êtes rédactrice en chef
et essayiste,
à L'Express
et Emmanuel Morel,
qui est avec nous
en visioconférence,
vous êtes député européen,
fondateur de la Gauche
républicaine et socialiste.
Alors, commençons
par la laïcité fourre-tout,
la laïcité
partout. Vous connaissez tous
le proverbe :
"Qui trop embrasse mal étreint."
A faire de la laïcité
un bouclier contre tous les maux,
n'y a-t-il pas un risque
de confusion sociale
et d'inefficacité politique ?
Monsieur Morel, qu'en pensez-vous ?
-Bah, déjà,
je trouve qu'on a tendance
ces derniers temps
à coller systématiquement
à la laïcité un adjectif.
On parle de laïcité ouverte,
stricte, moderne, inclusive,
exigeante, apaisée, positive.
Et la première des choses,
c'est de dire que la laïcité
n'a pas besoin d'adjectif
pour être définie.
Elle vise tout simplement
à ce que la société politique
détermine ses propres règles,
sans se référer
à une vérité révélée,
c'est-à-dire indépendamment
des préceptes d'une religion.
C'est ça, en réalité, la laïcité.
Au départ, c'est une société
qui se veut émancipée
de la tutelle de tous les clergés.
Là où vous avez raison
et j'ai bien aimé votre expression,
extension du domaine de la laïcité,
c'est qu'évidemment, ce concept,
ce principe a été pensé
à la fin du 19e,
au début du 20e siècle,
les choses ont depuis
beaucoup évolué.
Et quand je disais
débarrassée de la tutelle
des autorités ou des clergés,
c'est pas que les religions, ça peut
être l'autorité du marché,
ça peut être ce à quoi
vous faisiez allusion,
le communautarisme.
C'est vrai donc que la laïcité
s'est un peu étendue,
mais ce qui compte,
c'est le principe de base,
c'est-à-dire on sépare strictement
la politique de la religion.
Et ça, c'est très important,
surtout en ces temps
où on a un regain de la religiosité
dans les sociétés occidentales.
Et pas seulement occidentales
d'ailleurs.
-Qu'en pensez-vous, Iannis Roder ?
Vous partagez ?
-Oui, je partage ce qui vient
d'être dit par Emmanuel Morel.
Je pense qu'en effet,
ce qui a été pensé
à partir de la Révolution française
et jusqu'à la fin du 19e siècle
et la mise en place
de cette loi de séparation
de l'Eglise et de l'Etat est
toujours effectif aujourd'hui.
Et c'est un vrai...
atout de la République française,
d'avoir su justement
mettre en oeuvre
cette double émancipation,
dont Emmanuel Morel a parlé
en réalité,
c'est-à-dire cette émancipation
du politique vis-à-vis du religieux
et d'autre part, cette émancipation
du religieux vis-à-vis du politique.
Et cette neutralisation est
extrêmement importante dans le cadre
de la société apaisée que nous
appelons régulièrement de nos voeux.
-Vous êtes tous d'accord
là-dessus ?
Smaïn Laacher, vous partagez ?
Le juriste que vous êtes ?
-Oui. Oui, oui.
Je partage. Je partage les avis
qui viennent d'être donnés.
D'abord, la laïcité a
une longue histoire,
une très, très longue histoire.
Les historiens nous l'ont appris.
Il est vrai que la laïcité,
le mot est très polysémique
aujourd'hui.
C'est un enjeu
de débat et de polémique.
Mais
il est vrai que,
si je me réfère
au titre de votre...
de l'émission d'aujourd'hui,
est-ce que la laïcité peut tout ?
Non seulement
elle ne peut pas tout, mais ce n'est
pas son rôle de pourvoir à tout
ou d'essayer
de construire des solutions
quasiment intemporelles
et universelles.
Mais il est indéniable
que la laïcité à la française
est une donnée
très, très importante,
qui est au fondement de la société
dans laquelle
nous vivons aujourd'hui.
Laetitia
Strauch-Bonart, il y a une question
que je voudrais vous poser.
Vous, vous avez fait un reportage
à travers un très beau livre
sur la France.
Vous avez rencontré
beaucoup de Français. Vous ont-ils
beaucoup parlé de laïcité ?
Ou vous avez le sentiment
que c'est plutôt un concept
dans les cénacles
disons bien-pensants et influents ?
Mais au niveau des Français,
est-ce que vous avez senti
la prégnance,
l'importance de cette notion ?
-Je pense que la notion est, déjà,
connue depuis longtemps.
Elle est connue par tout le monde,
même si tout le monde
n'est pas forcément capable
de la définir précisément.
Elle fait partie
de l'histoire française.
La laïcité, c'est la sécularisation
dans sa version française.
La sécularisation qui est
le refus de l'intervention
du religieux en politique,
qui s'est passé à peu près partout
en Europe et aux Etats-Unis
dans des modalités
à chaque fois différentes.
Après, pour répondre aussi
à la question que vous posez
dans l'émission,
je pense qu'on a tendance
à brandir le terme
quand on ne sait pas
quoi dire d'autre.
Et on pense
que ça va être une solution
pour un certain nombre
de difficultés
qu'on peut rencontrer,
et notamment le fait religieux
qui connaît en effet
une nouvelle jeunesse en France,
notamment du fait
de la présence de musulmans
dans notre pays.
Moi, ce qui tend à me gêner
dans la conception française
de la laïcité,
c'est qu'elle signifie parfois
la détestation du religieux
ou son incompréhension, sa mise
à distance. Or je pense
qu'à l'origine, ça n'était pas ça.
A l'origine,
c'était la neutralité de l'Etat.
Aujourd'hui, dans le débat français,
beaucoup de gens brandissent
la laïcité simplement
parce qu'ils sont antireligieux.
Et en France, je constate souvent
une méconnaissance du fait religieux
qui est assez peu enseigné
en fait à l'école.
Or à mon avis on ne peut pas
comprendre la laïcité
et la sécularisation si on ne
comprend pas ce qu'est la religion
et pourquoi nos sociétés ont évolué
de façon à mettre
à distance la religion.
-Oui. Alors,
on va parler de la religion
et on va même parler
du fait religieux.
Mais restons, si vous voulez,
quelques instants,
sur la laïcité et ses problèmes.
Dans la société française
et notamment
dans le domaine de l'école,
est-ce que vous pourriez dire,
Monsieur Roder,
ce qui relève
d'un engagement laïc à l'école ?
C'est une vraie question.
On en parle sans arrêt.
-Qu'appelez-vous engagement laïc
à l'école ?
-L'école laïque et républicaine,
c'est quoi un engagement laïc ?
-L'engagement laïc de qui ?
Des enseignants ? De l'institution ?
-Des enseignants, des enseignés,
de l'administration.
-Pour l'administration
et les enseignants...
-Ca voudrait dire qu'on va à l'école
avec un engagement laïc.
-Alors, on ne va pas à l'école avec
un engagement laïc.
On est fonctionnaire
de la République.
Donc on se doit d'être neutre.
C'est ce que dit la loi de 1905.
-Si vous êtes neutres,
les élèves doivent l'être.
-Non. Ce n'est pas ce que dit
la loi. Les élèves n'ont pas
à être neutres. Les élèves peuvent
exprimer oralement
et aussi par des signes discrets
leurs convictions,
parfois même leur appartenance
religieuse s'ils le souhaitent.
Il n'y a pas de neutralité
demandée aux élèves.
-Les enseignants peuvent le faire ?
-Non.
Les enseignants
se doivent d'être neutres,
parce que l'idée derrière
cette neutralité de l'Etat,
c'est que chaque personne qui se
trouve en face d'un fonctionnaire
doit être traitée de la même manière
qu'un autre et qu'un fonctionnaire
n'a pas à tenir compte, ne doit pas
montrer de signe extérieur
d'appartenance.
-N'y a-t-il pas un problème
à dire qu'on est neutre ?
Par exemple, dans la sexualité,
il y a des hommes, des femmes,
maintenant on considère qu'il y a
une 3e catégorie, le sexe neutre.
Vis-à-vis des élèves,
quand vous dites, je suis neutre,
vous pensez qu'ils acceptent cela ?
-Ils n'ont pas le choix en réalité.
Un fonctionnaire doit être neutre.
C'est axiologique,
cette neutralité du fonctionnaire.
Donc je crois pas qu'il y ait
à discuter là-dessus.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
l'école laïque ?
Ca veut dire que le temps
de l'école, je ne parle pas
des fonctionnaires,
je parle là des élèves,
parce qu'ils vont à l'école laïque,
chaque élève met en suspens
le temps de l'école
ses appartenances premières
pour se mettre en situation
de recevoir les enseignements
qui vont lui être prodigués.
Ces enseignements
et c'est là qu'est la laïcité
dans l'enseignement,
la laïcisation
de l'enseignement,
ces enseignements vont reposer
sur la raison et sur la science.
-On va en parler. Monsieur Morel,
vous, en tant que député,
vous considérez que vous devez
être neutre en tant que député ?
C'est-à-dire vous êtes
un parlementaire neutre
du point de vue de la laïcité ?
-Bah je suis un parlementaire
laïc, c'est-à-dire
que je ne fais pas état
de mes éventuelles convictions,
mais ça ne va pas de soi.
Moi, je suis parlementaire européen.
Ca ne va pas du tout de soi
au niveau européen.
Comme vous le savez,
vous l'avez bien dit,
la laïcité à la française,
que nous chérissons
et que nous considérons comme une
condition du vouloir vivre ensemble,
ça ne va pas de soi dans les autres
pays européens. Vous avez des pays
avec des religions d'Etat, des pays
où les cultes sont subventionnés
et des pays où il est normal
que des élus affichent
leurs convictions religieuses,
participent
à des cérémonies religieuses, etc.
C'est pas le cas en France,
je m'en réjouis.
Je voudrais réagir à ce qu'a dit
Madame à l'instant.
-Madame Strauch-Bonart.
-Voilà. Il est bon de rappeler qu'en
aucun cas, la laïcité ne suppose
l'hostilité de la République
envers les religieux,
mais pas non plus la négation
du fait social religieux.
Au contraire,
c'est très important d'apprendre
et de savoir qu'il existe
différents cultes,
différentes histoires
et cultures,
mais je crains quand même que
le problème aujourd'hui ne soit pas
que la laïcité soit instrumentalisée
contre les religions,
c'est surtout que de plus en plus de
religieux mettent à mal
et contestent
le principe de la laïcité
et pas seulement
les fondamentalistes islamistes
comme on le dit parfois.
Il y en a d'autres.
Il y a les charismatiques,
les évangélistes,
certains catholiques intégristes
et d'autres
qui combattent la laïcité.
Et c'est en ça à mon avis
qu'il faut absolument la défendre.
Dernière chose, sur l'école,
très important évidemment,
je reviens pas sur ce qui a été dit,
je le partage,
mais quand même,
ce qu'il faut bien dire,
c'est que là aussi,
on a une forme d'offensive
contre l'école laïque.
Alors, il y a
des exemples dramatiques,
vous y avez fait allusion.
Au-delà de ça, il ne faudrait pas
que, de façon insidieuse,
on remette en cause
des enseignements qui sont fondés,
oui, c'est vrai,
sur la science, sur la raison,
et par qui, par définition,
ne reconnaissent aucun dogme
ou aucune vérité dite révélée.
Ca, c'est très important.
Evidemment, il en va de ce qu'est
le rôle même de l'école,
c'est-à-dire former
des citoyens éclairés
dans la liberté absolue
de conscience.
Donc là,
il y a besoin d'une vigilance
et c'est pour ça que moi,
j'ai une conception
quand même militante
de la laïcité, pas passive,
en aucun cas hostile aux religions,
mais quand même le rappel
d'un certain nombre de principes
qui, pour moi, sont la condition
même du vivre ensemble.
Vous dites laïcité à la française,
vous avez raison.
Nous, nous ne sommes pas
comme les Anglo-Saxons
qui considèrent que la société est
une juxtaposition de communautés.
La France s'est
construite différemment,
la République s'est construite
différemment et c'est bien
de le rappeler aujourd'hui.
-Smaïn Laacher.
-Oui, je voudrais juste
faire trois remarques.
La première, c'est celle concernant
ce que peuvent penser ou ce que
pensent les Français de la laïcité.
D'abord, les Français, c'est
un terme beaucoup trop général,
je ne sais pas de qui on parle
quand on parle des Français.
Est-ce qu'on parle
des patrons du CAC40 ?
Est-ce qu'on parle des ingénieurs ?
Est-ce qu'on parle des femmes ?
Je ne sais pas ce que c'est,
mais si je devais avoir recours
à mon expérience personnelle,
je suis sociologue,
donc je fais du terrain
depuis les années 80,
et il y a eu une époque
où on ne parlait pas de laïcité,
où il n'était pas question
de laïcité,
où la laïcité n'était pas
un enjeu politique,
un principe de division
entre les Français.
Même auprès des étrangers, hein.
Même auprès de gens
que l'on qualifie d'émigrés
ou d'enfants d'immigrés.
C'est après les années 80.
Et je pense qu'il y a eu
un tournant, c'est 2001.
C'est ce qui s'est passé
aux Etats-Unis en 2001.
C'est d'ailleurs à ce moment-là
qu'on a vu pour la première fois
en France autant de Corans
partir dans les librairies.
Bon. Le deuxième point,
c'est la place et le statut
de la religion dans une société.
Or nous sommes
en France, une histoire très
particulière de ce point de vue-là,
et je pense
que la laïcité, c'est d'abord
et avant tout, fondamentalement,
la liberté de croire
ou de ne pas croire.
Et en demandant à l'Etat
la plus grande neutralité.
En fait, l'Etat est agnostique.
L'Etat ne sait pas
ce que c'est qu'une croyance.
Il n'a pas à croire
ou à faire croire
tel ou tel dogme religieux.
Le dernier point,
c'est à propos de la laïcité
et de l'école, c'est un thème
extrêmement important.
Alors, moi, je n'emploierais pas
la notion d'offensive, parce que
l'offensive,
c'est quand même une configuration
très, très particulière, ce sont
des stratégies qui sont pensées,
c'est des modalités d'envahissement
de l'espace, d'institutions.
Je n'irais pas jusque-là.
En revanche, aujourd'hui
plus qu'hier, la question
de la laïcité est un enjeu
et pas seulement...
-Oui, mais Smaïn Laacher,
il faut préciser ça
pour nos téléspectateurs.
La question de la laïcité revient
très souvent par rapport
à des problèmes
esthétiques,
si je puis dire, à l'école.
Est-ce que vous considérez
que les tenues,
certaines tenues vestimentaires
sont un dérapage, quelque part
induisent un dérapage religieux,
ou c'est simplement
une conduite esthétique ?
-Alors, ça dépend
de quels vêtements vous parlez.
Il faut être précis.
-Je vous laisse alors dire
quels vêtements.
-Si vous parlez du dernier vêtement
qui a fait l'objet...
-Par exemple.
-...de polémiques,
je crois qu'il est inutile de faire
preuve d'hypocrisie collective
ou de mensonge à soi, ce vêtement
est un vêtement
dont la signification fondamentale
est une signification religieuse.
C'est pas la peine
de se mentir à soi-même,
le vêtement en soi et pour soi
peut ne pas avoir
de signification particulière.
Mais là, à l'évidence,
il a une signification particulière,
une signification religieuse
une signification
qui dit publiquement
l'appartenance à une vision du monde
et à une relation aux institutions
que l'on considère,
je dis bien que l'on considère,
comme des institutions
qui restent étrangères
à la vision du monde des gens
qui portent cet habit
qui dit à haute
et intelligible voix,
nous ne sommes peut-être pas
forcément pareils. Il y a
peut-être autre chose de plus
important, de plus puissant,
au-dessus de la République
et des lois de la République.
-En fait, la dernière chose
que vous venez de dire
est intéressante
et certainement chez les musulmans
aujourd'hui en France,
il y a différentes attitudes.
Il y a cette attitude
et il y a chez d'autres une attitude
beaucoup plus séculière.
Ce que j'essayais de dire,
qui a peut-être été mal compris,
c'est aussi que face à une vision du
monde comme celle que vous décrivez,
la réponse n'est pas de dire :
c'est la laïcité point,
parce que ça ne marchera pas.
Mon idée, c'est de dire que,
face à des gens vraiment convaincus
par l'importance de la religion,
qui pour eux est même
plus importante que tout le reste,
il faut s'y prendre
peut-être un peu différemment.
Je ne crois pas
que la confrontation,
que l'imposition
de la laïcité fonctionne.
Ca prend du temps et il faut
vraiment expliquer ce que c'est.
Et par ailleurs,
la question se pose aussi,
j'ai l'impression qu'on se met pas
dans la tête de ces personnes.
Quand ces personnes sont confrontées
à nous, qui sommes très laïcs
et parfois sans aucune religion
et pour qui le christianisme
n'a plus d'importance,
il peut y avoir chez eux
aussi un sentiment d'étrangeté
ou d'incompréhension
face à une culture où la religion
est quand même moins
importante, même
dans la sphère privée. La question
que nous pose la laïcité,
c'est : qu'en est-il d'un pays
où le christianisme n'a plus du tout
la place qu'il avait avant ?
Ce sont des questions qui nous sont
posées aussi à nous.
-Très bien. Iannis Roder.
-Je voulais d'abord nuancer
un peu
de ce que disait Smaïn Laacher
sur la question de l'offensive.
Si ma mémoire ne me fait pas défaut,
votre journal L'Express,
je crois, avait
sorti une note des services,
je ne sais plus
quels services, qui montrait
qu'il y avait sur les réseaux
sociaux une offensive
et qui était vraiment calculée,
a priori parce qu'on retrouvait
des éléments de langage,
aussi bien à Toulouse,
à Grenoble ou à Lille,
portés des jeunes filles,
pour justifier
le port de ce dont vous parliez,
de ces abayas.
S'il y a éléments
de langage identiques
à droite, à gauche,
c'est qu'il y a quelque part
quelque chose qui, derrière,
sans vouloir tomber
dans le complotisme,
mais qui tire
quelque part les ficelles
et qui en tout cas
cherche à instrumentaliser
les revendications identitaires
ou communautaires de ces jeunes.
C'est la 1re chose.
La 2e chose,
pour continuer
dans ce que vous disiez, il y a
un effort de pédagogie
à faire sur la laïcité.
Je rejoins Smaïn Laacher.
Mona Ozouf disait
dans un livre en 82,
la laïcité, c'est réglé,
tout le monde est d'accord,
même les catholiques.
10 ans après, boum,
on n'est plus
du tout, enfin,
après l'affaire de Creil,
en 89 en réalité,
il y a eu des affaires
du foulard avant,
mais qui n'avaient pas été
publicisées.
Creil, c'est 89, donc c'est là,
on se rend compte que non,
c'est pas si simple que ça.
Et on sait très bien après
que, voilà,
jusqu'à aujourd'hui,
une vraie question nous est posée.
Il faut faire oeuvre de pédagogie
en rappelant systématiquement
cette idée de liberté justement.
La laïcité, il faut la présenter
de manière positive. Et c'est vrai
que les élèves, la plupart du temps,
quand vous demandez ce qu'est
la laïcité,
vous disent interdiction.
Il faut retourner la chose.
Pas interdiction, liberté.
Liberté. Liberté de conscience.
Liberté de culte.
Il faut mettre cela
absolument en avant.
Il faut former
les enseignants
et très bien les former.
-Monsieur Morel,
je voudrais avec vous
évoquer une question qui fâche.
Est-ce que vous accordez
du crédit politique
à la notion d'insécurité culturelle
évoquée par un républicain,
Laurent Bouvet, qui considère que
certains citoyens, se considérant
comme des citoyens de souche,
peuvent ressentir
une insécurité culturelle
quand ils ne retrouvent pas,
si vous voulez,
leur pré carré,
la France qui était la leur,
celle de leurs grands-parents, etc.
-Là, on s'éloigne un tout petit peu
du débat. Il se trouve que Laurent
Bouvet était un ami très cher.
Il nous a quittés, hélas,
il y a maintenant plus d'un an.
Il avait forgé ce concept, qui a
d'ailleurs fait beaucoup débat,
qui a été contesté par un certain
nombre de collègues à lui,
mais je pense
que Laurent Bouvet était
un observateur assez fin
de ce qui se passait
dans la société.
Et justement, je rebondis
sur l'histoire de l'offensive.
Moi, je maintiens
qu'il y a une offensive
et que cette offensive souvent,
elle commence par l'école.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'il y a
des courants religieux,
qui sont des courants
fondamentalistes, rigoristes,
qui visent à imposer une certaine
vision de la société
et à considérer que toutes personnes
supposément appartenant
à leur communauté
doivent agir de la sorte.
Donc oui, il y a du prosélytisme.
Oui, il y a des provocations.
Et oui, nous devons nous défendre,
non pas parce que la laïcité serait
quelque chose de violent
ou d'excluant,
mais précisément, c'est
très important ce qu'a dit
Monsieur Roder à l'instant,
parce que nous défendons la liberté.
Et la liberté,
c'est la liberté de croire,
mais c'est aussi
la liberté de ne pas croire. Je veux
la liberté pour les incroyants,
les agnostiques, les athées.
-Est-ce qu'il y a ce prosélytisme
au sein du Parlement européen ?
-Oui.
Alors, nous avons été confrontés
en effet à plusieurs cas.
D'abord, vous avez
le prosélytisme traditionnel
des catholiques
notamment qui viennent de l'Est.
Vous voyez bien,
la Pologne et d'autres pays.
Pour qui l'Europe n'est
que chrétienne. En réalité.
Et donc,
il y a des tentatives répétées
pour imposer une vision
totalement univoque
de l'Union européenne dont le seul
héritage serait chrétien.
Mais vous avez aussi,
plus récemment,
des institutions européennes qui,
sous prétexte
de valoriser la diversité
au sein de l'Union européenne, se
sont mises à faire de la publicité
pour le port du hijab, par exemple,
avec une campagne financée
par le Conseil de l'Europe,
qui disait la beauté dans le hijab,
la liberté dans le hijab,
que nous avons contestée également,
nous, députés européens,
parce que justement
nous voulons une société
qui reconnaît évidemment le fait
religieux, la diversité culturelle,
mais qui ne fasse pas de publicité
pour une foi ou pour une autre foi.
-Considérez-vous
que la corruption financière
évoquée dernièrement
est aussi une atteinte
à la laïcité ?
-Oui, alors, là, vous faites
allusion au Qatar Gate.
Il y a des allégations très graves
à l'encontre de collègues
qui auraient été corrompus
par le Qatar.
Je vais vous dire la vérité,
là, bon, c'est déjà
une affaire de gros sous.
Mais quand même,
là où vous avez peut-être raison,
c'est que le Qatar a une stratégie
politique très sophistiquée
au sein du monde occidental,
qui consiste bien sûr
à financer un certain
nombre de structures, à acheter
un certain nombre d'institutions,
de clubs de football, etc.,
pour faire aussi la promotion
d'une certaine idée
de la foi et, en l'occurrence,
une idée très rigoriste,
voire agressive.
Mais je finis juste un mot,
parce que je ne veux pas oublier,
sur l'école et sur... Parce que
Madame Strauch-Bonart disait :
il ne faut pas donner l'impression
aux croyants et notamment les jeunes
qu'on est dans le mépris
ou dans le dénigrement.
Je partage tout à fait cet avis.
Mais il faut quand même
faire preuve d'un minimum
de pédagogie
et rappeler au sein de l'école
que la foi ne saurait prévaloir
sur le savoir.
Pourquoi je dis ça ? Parce que,
et ça, c'est un phénomène nouveau,
on est quand même obligés
de rappeler un certain nombre
de choses scientifiques
et rationnelles. Le monde n'a
pas été créé en 7 jours.
Adam et Eve ne sont pas
nos arrière-grands-parents.
La terre n'est pas plate. Etc. Etc.
Pourquoi je dis ça ?
Parce qu'à la faveur des réseaux
sociaux, des fake news
et aussi de la prégnance
de certaines idéologies religieuses,
on en revient à remettre en cause
des choses quand même fondamentales
dans l'apprentissage du savoir.
Donc forcément, il faut se défendre
et forcément, il faut se défendre
quand il y a une offensive.
C'est ce que nous faisons
toutes et tous.
Et les Français sont quand même
attachés à la laïcité.
-Non, mais là,
enfin, bon, c'est un peu
exagéré, parce que j'ai pas vraiment
défendu la lecture religieuse
de la création du monde.
C'est le cas dans tous les...
Ca ne dépend pas que du modèle laïc,
dans tous les pays occidentaux
et plein d'autres pays,
on fait la différence
entre la science,
la raison et la foi.
Là, je veux dire...
Le sujet n'est pas...
Voilà un exemple où on est en train
de demander à la laïcité
quelque chose
qui n'est peut-être pas son rôle.
La distinction entre la science et
la foi, il me semble qu'elle est
de l'ordre de la sécularisation,
qui est plus large.
-Monsieur Laacher,
je vais vous donner la parole.
Mais si c'est pour aborder
les questions religieuses,
on va les aborder en 2e partie.
Mais je vous laisse parler.
-Je ne voulais pas aborder
la question de la religion.
D'abord, parce que je n'ai
pas de compétence particulière
n'étant pas théologien
et n'ayant pas fait
d'études de théologie.
-Nous vivons une société
où tout le monde
s'exprime sur tout.
-En revanche, ce qui me semble
important, c'est cette notion
d'offensive.
C'est une notion importante,
parce qu'elle a
des effets performatifs.
Les mots ont leur importance.
Non pas que je récuse totalement,
mais je suis très prudent
sur la notion,
parce que l'offensive suggère
qu'il y ait un bastion à prendre.
Or je ne suis pas sûr
qu'il y ait un bastion
à prendre et puis,
et alors là, je fais
le sociologue, hein,
je voudrais voir
et je voudrais savoir
dans quels établissements
il y a ce type
de pratiques, ce type
de conduites, qui est
une conduite de confrontation
et d'affrontement
à l'égard de l'institution scolaire.
Où se trouvent ces établissements ?
Qui porte cette abaya ?
D'où viennent les gens
qui portent cette abaya ?
Est-ce une immigration récente ?
Une vieille immigration ?
Personne ne le sait
pour le moment, parce que
tout le monde est focalisé
sur le vêtement. Mais la dimension
sociologique,
le vêtement recontextualisé,
l'histoire de ce vêtement,
pas en l'air,
c'est pas
une histoire stratosphérique,
c'est une histoire qui a un sens
parmi les populations
qui pensent
que cette abaya
doit être vue
par tout le monde,
quel que soit le lieu,
quelle que soit l'institution.
Donc il faut voir de plus près.
Et je voudrais juste préciser
que, en tout cas
pour ce que je sais,
donc c'est pas...
c'est pas un savoir...
c'est pas un savoir qui ne peut pas
être remis en cause,
mais les jeunes femmes
qui portent cette abaya
sont des jeunes filles
qui sont nées en France.
Qui sont nées en France.
Et d'ailleurs, peut-être,
peut-être sont-elles même
en désaccord avec les parents.
Ca non plus, on ne le sait pas.
Mais ils ne viennent pas
d'un autre pays.
Ils ne sont pas issus
d'un autre continent et surtout,
surtout, il faut être sérieux
quand on parle
de ces choses-là,
je défie quiconque de me dire
que les jeunes femmes
qui portent l'abaya
à une quelconque culture religieuse.
Et je suis intimement persuadé
que ce savoir approximatif,
ce savoir
totalement bricolé,
ce savoir ad hoc
pour faire face à l'institution,
en fait,
c'est de la 2e, 3e ou 4e main
de gens qui effectivement, là,
peuvent y voir
une manière d'entrer
dans une institution très importante
pour récupérer des gens
qui incarnent l'avenir.
Et donc ils ne sont pas
dans une offensive à l'égard
de l'institution scolaire,
ils sont dans des stratégies,
enfin, c'est pas des stratégies,
dans des tactiques
de petits pas pour conquérir
le plus d'espace possible
dans la société française.
-Alors, on va maintenant
rentrer de plain-pied
dans les relations entre laïcité
et religion. En France,
d'après les statistiques actuelles,
mais qui sont valables
pour les 10 dernières années,
on considère qu'il y a à peu près
35 à 40 % de croyants,
moins de non-croyants, 31 %,
15 % d'agnostiques.
Ces chiffres
varient un peu, mais il y a
quand même une stabilité.
Comment faire pour assurer
une présence du religieux
sans porter atteinte à la laïcité
et au regard du fait que
l'enseignement des faits religieux
qui a été prôné
n'est pas une réussite ?
Laetitia Strauch-Bonart.
-Vous répondez en partie
à la question. Je pense que
l'enseignement du fait religieux
devrait être plus important.
Moi, dans mon cursus scolaire,
qui n'est pas si loin que ça,
je n'ai rien appris sur la religion
et je le regrette,
parce que ce sont
des faits de civilisation
et on ne peut pas considérer que des
milliers et des milliers d'années
de vie humaine
avec une forte
pratique religieuse
ne représentent rien, même
si aujourd'hui nous sommes très loin
de tout ça pour différentes raisons.
Donc je pense qu'on devrait avoir
une attitude un peu plus humble
vis-à-vis du fait religieux.
Je le dis moi-même sans être
pratiquante ou affiliée
à une religion.
-On peut être pratiquant.
Rassurez-vous, si vous l'étiez,
vous seriez pas
excommuniée de ce plateau.
-Je ne défends pas ma paroisse
en l'occurrence.
Mais le fait religieux a
beaucoup à nous apprendre
notamment parce que,
dans les textes religieux,
il y a quand même, il y a
des éléments de sagesse aussi
qui n'ont pas disparu
de nos sociétés. Le monde n'a pas
recommencé au moment
des Lumières. D'ailleurs,
selon certains philosophes,
les Lumières peut-être
n'auraient pas existé
sans des éléments religieux,
notamment le christianisme,
parce que, déjà,
dans le christianisme,
vous trouvez
la racine de la sécularisation,
c'est-à-dire la séparation
entre l'Etat,
le public et le privé. Ce sont
des choses passionnantes
qu'on n'apprend pas forcément
parce qu'on a peur de la religion.
En France, on a peur de la religion.
-Iannis Roder,
vous êtes enseignant, arrivez-vous
à enseigner les versets
du Talmud, les hadiths
du Coran, les Evangiles ?
Est-ce que vous arrivez à le faire
d'une manière laïque ?
-Vous savez...
-Et quel sens ça a
et comment faut-il s'y prendre ?
-Je n'ai pas en tant que
fonctionnaire de la République,
je dois suivre les programmes
scolaires. Les programmes scolaires
ne me demandent pas d'enseigner
ce que dit le Talmud,
ce que dit le Coran
ou ce que disent les Evangiles.
En revanche, tous ces ouvrages
peuvent être des sources
et sont vus et utilisés
comme des sources
à l'instar d'autres sources.
-Pardonnez-moi, Monsieur Roder,
quand vous parlez,
je prends certains préceptes,
"tu ne tueras point", "tu aimerais
ton prochain comme toi-même",
"tu pratiqueras
"la charité", etc.
Ca a quand même
un substrat religieux.
Est-ce que vous l'évoquez quand
vous leur enseignez ces choses-là ?
-Alors... Vous savez...
Je crois et c'est très important
d'abord qu'il faut
absolument recontextualiser
ces histoires-là.
Il faut les remettre dans
le contexte historique. A partir
du moment où on remet
dans le contexte historique,
on peut aborder ces questions-là.
Ce livre dit cela,
voilà ce que cela signifie
pour ceux qui adhèrent à cela,
mais vous devez vous mettre, vous,
en retrait et avoir cette position,
on va dire, scientifique,
ce regard qui se veut un regard
objectif et distancié.
C'est absolument essentiel. Donc,
on peut tout enseigner dès lors
que vous avez cette attitude. C'est
ce qu'on demande à un enseignant,
cette distanciation
et cette neutralité
vis-à-vis du discours
qu'il a lu.
C'est extrêmement important.
Je voudrais revenir
sur quelque chose.
Ce qui me semble important
aujourd'hui, c'est que nous avons
un corps enseignant qui,
en grande partie, en tout cas
dans le public, est très détaché
de ces questions religieuses,
et parce qu'ils sont passés
par la même école que Madame,
ces enseignants souvent n'ont jamais
entendu parler
de religions
et de ce que cela signifie.
Et donc parfois ont du mal
à comprendre ce que peut avoir
de profond la foi
et de fort, c'est-à-dire
de dynamique qu'elle peut porter.
Et ça, il y a quelque chose qui
se passe parfois dans les classes,
une espèce finalement
de confrontation,
qui peut rester apaisée,
mais d'incompréhension.
Quand on a un regard
sur une religion
ou sur la croyance d'une manière
générale, qui est un regard
un peu exotique, on regarde ça
un peu "ah, il croit encore",
ça arrive, c'est comme ça, on a
du mal à comprendre ce que disent
certains élèves
et ce à quoi ils s'attachent.
C'est un vrai problème,
d'où l'intérêt de penser
un véritable enseignement laïc
des faits religieux.
Ca veut dire quoi ?
Ca veut dire comment,
quelles sont les visions du monde
qui président à ces religions ?
-Monsieur Roder,
quand on nous enseigne l'économie,
par exemple,
on peut avoir un enseignant
qui est marxiste ou libéral
et on s'interroge pas
s'il est marxiste ou libéral.
-Vous pensez que les élèves
ne s'interrogent pas ?
-Non, mais je vous pose
la question. Pourquoi c'est plus
difficile avec la religion ?
On a peur de religions ?
-Pour ce que je viens de vous dire.
Je pense qu'il y a une grande
ignorance dans le corps enseignant,
je généralise et je ne devrais pas.
Le sociologue qu'est Smaïn Laacher
comprend qu'il ne faut pas
généraliser, évidemment.
Mais d'une manière générale quand
même, vous me permettrez de penser
que le corps enseignant
dans le public
est très éloigné de ces questions.
Donc il y a une gêne,
il y a peut-être
une insécurité intellectuelle
quand on aborde
ces questions-là,
d'autant plus que vous avez parfois
des élèves vindicatifs,
Emmanuel Morel l'a dit
et je suis assez d'accord.
Donc voilà, il y a une... Oui,
un malaise.
Donc il y aurait un gros travail
de formation à faire
sur ces questions-là.
Sur la question de l'économie,
il y a moins d'enjeux on va dire.
C'est pas parce que...
Enfin, vous savez, on n'a pas...
On a assassiné,
vous l'avez dit, on a décapité, on a
assassiné et décapité un enseignant
sur des questions religieuses.
-Ecoutez,
Monsieur Smaïn Laacher,
on va laisser l'école de côté,
et je voudrais interroger
peut-être le juriste
que vous êtes sur un point
précis concernant
la liberté d'expression.
La liberté d'expression, c'est
un principe révolutionnaire
qui date depuis avant
la loi sur la laïcité.
Est-ce que vous considérez
que, par exemple, à l'Assemblée
nationale, dans les débats,
quand on se jette
plus que des noms d'oiseau,
quand il y a des dérives verbales,
quand il y a d'autres dérives
verbales sur les réseaux sociaux,
est-ce que ça, ce sont des atteintes
à la laïcité, puisque tout est mis
sous le couvert
d'une défense de la laïcité ?
-Alors, pour des raisons de méthode,
je séparerais quand même l'Assemblée
nationale des réseaux sociaux.
Je suppose qu'on n'y dit pas
la même chose,
que les débats ne sont pas organisés
de la même manière,
et on ne se lâche pas
de la même manière
à l'Assemblée nationale
que sur les réseaux sociaux.
Moi, je pense
qu'on peut tout dire
dès lors que ce qui est dit
n'est pas un discours qui appelle
à la haine et n'est pas un discours
qui trouble l'ordre public.
-Mais ça, c'est un principe
général.
-Non, non.
Ca peut être un principe
qu'on fait sien
et qui peut produire
des effets d'autocensure.
Je n'insulte pas. Si j'étais député,
je n'insulterais pas quelqu'un
parce qu'il a une couleur de peau
qui serait différente de la mienne.
Je n'insulterais pas quelqu'un
parce qu'il fait partie
des 89 députés du Front national.
Et voyez-vous, alors,
je le dis, c'est même public,
si on vient me serrer la main,
si quelqu'un du Front national
vient me serrer la main,
je ne lui refuserai pas ma main.
Parce qu'une main qui est donnée,
c'est une main
qui est désarmée,
c'est une main qui n'a pas
d'arme et donc je ne vois pas
pourquoi je refuserais
de lui serrer la main,
même si on ne va pas dîner ensemble
et même si on ne prend pas
le café ensemble.
Donc la liberté d'expression
est quelque chose
d'extrêmement précieux.
D'extrêmement précieux.
Que l'on peut remettre
en cause à chaque moment.
C'est quelque chose qui a été
douloureusement acquis.
-Vous dites
que vous êtes
pour la liberté d'expression
jusqu'au droit au blasphème ?
-Absolument. Alors là,
sans aucune hésitation possible.
Et je dis même qu'on peut même
offenser des croyances
ou on peut...
Mettons de côté le mot offenser,
on peut critiquer
radicalement
les croyances, les dogmes...
-Mais certains considèrent que c'est
un trouble à l'ordre public.
-Non. Critiquer la religion
n'est pas un trouble
à l'ordre public.
Sinon vous supprimez
Charlie Hebdo. Non.
Le blasphème est, si je puis dire,
si je puis m'exprimer ainsi,
blasphématoire
si on s'en prend aux personnes,
c'est-à-dire aux croyants,
mais si on s'en prend aux dogmes,
si la critique s'exerce
et se déploie
à l'égard des dogmes,
à l'égard des croyances,
à l'égard des visions du monde,
il n'y a pas de...
-On vous a entendu.
Monsieur Morel, je sais
que vous voulez intervenir,
mais je voudrais
ajouter une question,
ça nous permettrait
d'avancer dans le débat.
L'intolérance religieuse conduit
à la répression
de jeunes femmes en Afghanistan
et au meurtre en Iran,
où des gens sont assassinés,
quelquefois sauvagement
et on pourrait considérer,
c'est ce que nous considérons
comme des crimes d'Etat.
Est-ce qu'à votre avis, ça justifie
un droit et un devoir
international d'ingérence ?
-Oh là là, ça, c'est
une très vaste question que
nous ne réglerons pas en 5 minutes.
-Le point de vue du législateur
que vous êtes est intéressant
et important, puisque vous êtes
à la fois un législateur
et avec une casquette européenne.
-Le législateur considère qu'il faut
sanctionner et sanctionner durement
les pays qui se livrent
à de tels agissements.
Et d'ailleurs ce qui est fait
à l'encontre de l'Iran,
mais aussi de l'Afghanistan
avec le retour des talibans,
donc à la fois sanction et soutien,
soutien inlassable
aux femmes et aux hommes,
parce qu'en Iran,
c'est quelque chose de formidable.
La mobilisation des femmes
est soutenue massivement
par les jeunes hommes
qui, au péril de leur vie,
parce qu'on parle d'une jeunesse
martyrisée, opprimée,
défend le droit de vivre libre.
Donc ça, c'est la 1re chose.
La 2e chose,
vous avez dit droit au blasphème,
mais en France, il n'y a pas
de droit au blasphème,
tout simplement parce que
le blasphème, ça n'existe pas.
La loi française ne reconnaît pas
le blasphème
justement parce que
nous sommes un Etat laïc,
liberté de croire ou non,
il n'y a pas de religion d'Etat.
S'il y a bien
une tradition française
qu'il faut perpétuer et chérir,
c'est le droit à l'irrévérence,
à la satire, à la critique,
fût-elle radicale,
des dogmes, des religions
et des clergés.
Justement, si on a été aussi
nombreux à se mobiliser
au moment du drame de Charlie Hebdo,
c'est parce que je pense que les
assassins avaient aussi touché
quelque chose
de spécifiquement français
qui date de très loin,
Voltaire et même avant,
jusqu'à Rabelais,
qui consiste à moquer
parfois les dogmes
et ceux qui les professent.
Enfin, dernière chose, parce que
c'est une question très importante,
je crois qu'il faut enseigner
le fait religieux,
comme on enseigne tous les récits
fondateurs des civilisations.
C'est très important
de connaître la Bible,
comme c'est très important
de connaître Homère,
pour une raison simple aussi, à
partir du moment où on s'ouvre
au monde de l'art, la peinture,
la littérature, la musique,
bien sûr qu'on va retrouver
des éléments de la Bible,
du Nouveau
et de l'Ancien Testament.
Moi, je suis par exemple un
fanatique de Jean-Sébastien Bach.
Jean-Sébastien Bach est pétri
de culture religieuse.
Nicolas Poussin en peinture,
c'est pareil.
C'est bien donc de connaître les
dogmes qui ont inspiré les oeuvres.
Mais tout en ayant, et là je rejoins
totalement Monsieur Roder,
ce qu'il a appelé, je crois,
un regard objectif et distancié.
Et c'est là
que c'est parfois compliqué.
Et je reviens encore une fois,
Madame Strauch-Bonart va croire
que je veux
absolument débattre avec elle, non,
mais elle dit, science et foi,
le débat est réglé depuis longtemps.
Ce n'est pas vrai.
Aujourd'hui, cela ne va pas de soi.
Je vais vous prendre un pays
qui est spécialiste d'une forme
de relativisme, les Etats-Unis,
où certains Etats aujourd'hui
ne tolèrent pas qu'on enseigne
certaines choses en biologie
et en histoire
au nom du créationnisme.
Je m'excuse, mais c'est un combat
qui est encore d'actualité.
-J'ai pas du tout dit...
-Vous avez dit...
-Elle va vous répondre.
-...que le débat entre science
et foi était réglé. D'ailleurs,
aujourd'hui, la menace n'est plus
tant celle des créationnistes
que d'une certaine gauche wok.
Pardon,
je ne pensais pas évoquer ça,
mais qui nie aussi
les vérités scientifiques
au nom de l'idéologie.
-Je suis d'accord.
On ne doit pas nier les vérités
scientifiques au nom des idéologies.
-Ce que j'essayais de dire, c'est
que ça n'est pas propre à la laïcité
de vouloir séparer
la science et la foi.
-Ah oui, d'accord.
Si c'est ça, d'accord.
-Et j'ajouterais aussi,
mais peut-être
que ça va moins vous plaire,
qu'il y a beaucoup
de grands scientifiques
qui sont aussi très croyants.
La séparation entre science et foi,
elle se fait parfois
à l'intérieur des individus.
C'est cette complexité de l'être
humain que je trouve intéressante.
Après, vous me direz, face à
certaines difficultés aujourd'hui,
on est très loin de cet enjeu
et l'enjeu, il est plus compliqué,
mais en même temps plus simple,
de dire, vous mettez la foi
en votre for intérieur
et vous apprenez la science,
parce que c'est comme ça
que nos sociétés fonctionnent.
Mais on n'est pas tellement
en désaccord.
-Je voulais juste, c'est très court,
je voulais juste rectifier
ou plus exactement préciser
ce que j'avais dit tout à l'heure
sur la question du blasphème.
En fait, la question du blasphème
ou le problème du blasphème,
c'est d'abord
un problème des dévots,
c'est pas du tout
le problème des blasphémateurs.
C'est d'abord le problème des gens
qui se sentent blasphémés.
-Le monde évolue.
Il n'est pas dicté uniquement
par l'universalisme français.
On observe
ce communautarisme partout
et on observe
une division du monde aujourd'hui
entre des pays autoritaires
avec quelquefois
de véritables dictatures.
Est-ce que, à votre avis,
au regard de cette évolution
stratégique, socioculturelle,
la laïcité française
doit rester immuable,
une exception culturelle
ou nécessite-t-elle
quelques adaptations ?
Laetitia Strauch-Bonart.
On a un peu de temps,
mais c'est un peu la conclusion,
si vous voulez,
qu'on voudrait dire, donner. Voilà.
-J'ai du mal à voir en quoi
la laïcité doit être reliée
à des problématiques
internationales.
Vous semblez relier
les deux et dire...
-Oui, parce que la France
est dans le monde.
-Oui, mais...
-La culture n'est pas que française.
-Bien sûr,
mais c'est pas parce que
des dictatures s'affirment
que notre position
sur la laïcité a varié,
il me semble. On
a déjà des débats intérieurs
suffisamment complexes
entre gens qui sont
plus ou moins d'accord.
Enfin, moi,
je vois pas forcément
un enjeu international,
à moins que j'aie mal compris
votre question.
-Vous ne voyez pas
la possibilité de variation
anthropologique en quelque sorte
par rapport à ce qui se passe
dans le monde aujourd'hui ?
-Au niveau international,
il y a une pression,
notamment par l'intermédiaire
de la presse nord-américaine,
par exemple,
sur la laïcité française.
Je pense au New York Times,
au Washington Post.
Qui ne comprennent absolument pas ce
que veut dire la laïcité française
et qui, de fait, défendent
un autre modèle culturel et donc
un autre modèle politique.
Je suis d'accord avec vous,
c'est-à-dire : et alors ?
Les Américains pensent
ce qu'ils veulent.
Ils n'ont pas notre histoire,
ils n'ont pas la profondeur
de notre histoire et ils n'ont pas
notre conception républicaine.
C'est une autre conception.
Nous nous sommes construits sur
cette idée, sur cette conception,
au coeur de laquelle nous trouvons
la laïcité. Je ne vois pas pourquoi,
parce qu'il se passe
des choses en Amérique du Nord
ou il se passe d'autres choses
ailleurs, nous aurions
à changer ce modèle.
Je pense que ce modèle,
il a fait justement ses preuves.
Nous vivons jusqu'à preuve
du contraire dans une société
beaucoup plus apaisée
que la société notamment
nord-américaine, la laïcité
n'y est pas étrangère.
-Monsieur Laacher.
-Si on reste dans le nord,
bien évidemment, ces débats sont
importants et la question
de l'universalisation de l'universel
effectivement est un débat
qui ne cesse
de circuler dans les pays du nord.
Si vous descendez, si vous allez
dans les pays du sud,
et pour une aire
géopolitico-culturelle
que je connais un petit peu,
qui est le monde arabe, par exemple,
la question de la laïcité
pour certains
et pour de plus en plus de personnes
est un enjeu très important.
Je pense en particulier...
-On ne peut pas développer.
-Mais pourtant, c'est important.
Si on devait faire preuve
de solidarité par exemple
avec les femmes afghanes,
avec les Iraniennes, etc.,
eh bien, il faut penser
que, dans ces pays-là,
pour certaines fractions
de ces populations,
l'universel existe,
la laïcité peut exister.
La laïcité, c'est
simplement la disjonction
entre le temporel et le spirituel.
-Merci. Monsieur Morel, un point
pour conclure.
Est-ce que ça doit rester immuable
ou vous qui êtes au contact
de 27, voire plus de pays européens,
est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose
à bouger ou ça doit rester ?
-D'abord, j'abonde totalement
dans le sens de Monsieur Laacher.
Je suis président
de la délégation Maghreb
au Parlement européen
et pour bien fréquenter les sociétés
civiles des pays du Maghreb,
la question de la laïcité,
du rapport à la religion,
ne va pas de soi et que des gens
aujourd'hui se battent
pour conquérir ce type de droits.
Je finirai en reprenant vos propos.
Vous avez parlé d'universalisme.
Justement, au moment où se
multiplient les différentialismes,
au moment où croît parfois
ce qu'on appelle le relativisme,
il est bien de redire,
que ça soit français ou non,
il est bien de redire qu'il y a
des principes qui sont universels.
Ce que nous prouve le combat
des femmes iraniennes, par exemple,
c'est qu'il y a
des principes universels,
qui valent partout dans le monde
et pas seulement
sur tel ou tel territoire.
C'est une leçon formidable.
L'universalisme est contesté,
à droite, aussi parfois à gauche,
il faut qu'il y ait
de plus en plus de gens
qui continuent à le défendre.
-Merci beaucoup.
Alors, je dois vous présenter
une brève bibliographie.
Smaïn Laacher, vous avez publié
"L'affaire Mila,
"victime, agresseurs,
haine en ligne",
Fondation Jean Jaurès et L'Aube.
Je voudrais également signaler
un autre ouvrage
que vous avez publié
et qui s'appelle :
à L'Aube.
Laetitia Strauch-Bonart,
nous avons déjà présenté
votre livre
au cours d'une émission précédente.
On l'a évoqué
au cours de l'émission,
"De la France",
c'est à la fois édité par Perrin
et Presses de la Cité.
Donc c'est, j'allais dire,
une balade, enfin, une balade,
c'est une excursion
quasiment ethnologique
et culturelle
de ce que sont
les Français aujourd'hui.
Alors, je voudrais,
Monsieur Iannis Roder,
vous avez publié
un livre, alors dont on a
beaucoup parlé, en tout cas
au cours de cette émission,
à savoir "La jeunesse française,
l'école et la République".
C'est le témoignage
de votre exercice professionnel.
-C'est pas seulement
le témoignage,
c'est aussi une analyse de beaucoup
d'enquêtes sur ces questions.
-C'est donc une analyse
de beaucoup d'enquêtes.
Vous voyez, on part
du particulier, mais
à l'universel.
Et je dois signaler
aussi, puisqu'on a parlé
de Laurent Bouvet, "Portrait
"d'un intellectuel engagé".
Ca a été publié aux éditions
de l'Observatoire. Monsieur Morel,
vous voulez signaler un livre.
Vous avez publié
plusieurs ouvrages, qui sont pas
dans le cadre de la laïcité,
mais je vous laisse en signaler
un seul si vous voulez bien
avant de terminer cette émission.
-D'abord,
j'ai contribué au livre
sur Laurent Bouvet.
Je vous le recommande vraiment.
J'y ai fait un long article.
Je vous recommande
un livre pratique :
C'est un avocat,
qui s'appelle Philippe Bluteau,
qui répond à toutes les questions
pratiques que peuvent se poser
les élus, mais aussi les citoyens,
sur la laïcité au quotidien.
C'est très bien fait et tout
un rappel de la jurisprudence
des juridictions administratives.
-Merci beaucoup.
Je voudrais vous remercier,
madame,
messieurs,
d'avoir participé à cette émission,
remercier l'équipe de LCP.
Et, avant de vous quitter,
je voudrais vous laisser
avec cette pensée, je voudrais
rendre hommage ici à Samuel Paty
jet donc je vous laisse
avec cette pensée :
"C'est un débat essentiel
"de convaincre la jeunesse
de la puissance
"de nos valeurs universelles
"et de la laïcité
synonyme de liberté.
"L'enseignant Samuel Paty est mort
pour avoir défendu cette liberté."
C'est une pensée,
une citation de Manuel Valls.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA